The Joe Rogan Experience Jimmy I watched
your your whole series on Atlanta all
day today I've been watching for hours
I've been watching the impact videos
videos about the the Atlanta structure
and so let's just get into it let's do
it so the Rashad structure I was on your
show a little over a year ago and shared
some details about it to people who
aren't aware there's a location in the
western Sahara Desert of Mauritania
called the Rishad structure it's also
commonly referred to as the eye of the
Sahara
it is a site that most people have never
seen or heard of before which is truly
peculiar because it's so spectacular
it's a site that astronauts typically
use to reference from space it is a
geological feature that is said to be
volcanic in nature and what's so
spectacular about this is that it just
so happens to match more than a dozen
striking similarities to what Plato had
described as the Lost ancient capital
city of Atlantis I almost feel like
we're not going to do your video Justice
by just talking about it because the
video is so good and you go into so many
details by the end of it my jaw was
dropped I was like holy [ __ ] like from
what you had the last time you were on
the podcast to what you put out now it's
even more compelling like way more
compelling I appreciate you saying that
and I guess to anyone that wants to
check it out I have a YouTube channel
called bright Insight it's right at the
top of the page and it says lost ancient
Roman map has Atlantis and Sahara Africa
and that's kind of where it goes from
there is that there is a actually let me
just mention real quick like you're a
very inquisitive individual you have
many interesting people that come and
chat with you
and when I had asked you last time you
said that until you had saw my video
you'd never seen or heard of them yeah
anytime I meet somebody new or if I'm at
some party like oh what do you do we
start chatting about YouTube the first
thing I do now is I show them a picture
of the wrist shot and I've never not
once ever come across one single person
that has seen or heard of it before
other than people who are familiar with
what I've shared but there's so many
things like the the where the water
flows to the South where there's clear
evidence of water erosion that took
place after the volcano there's so much
that points to that possibly being
Atlantis it's spectacular so just to run
down real quick Plato had described
Atlantis as being the capital let me
just mention that because it was an
Empire said to be made up of ten
kingdoms and what I'm focusing on is the
Lost capital city which was said to be
made up of concentric circles three of
water two of land which matches the rift
structure it also is said to have an
opening to the Sea at the South and if
you look at it from satellite imagery
you can clearly see that Waterhead ran
through it let's take a look at that put
tell Jimmy what image to pull up so we
can
um and furthermore it was said to have
mountains to the north and you just so
happen to have mountains called the
Atlas mountain chain which Atlas was
said to be the very first king of
Atlantis and what's interesting is that
the very first known king of Mauritania
which is where the Risha structure is
located is also their very first known
King was also named Atlas and though I'm
not saying that that's the same
individual but what we do today is we
pass down names right like people like
oh my dad's name is John and so is so is
my son and so it's it's another striking
similarity but it goes further than that
like there's geological similarities
such as the fact that Atlantis was said
to be made up of red black and white
color stone which is another similarity
you see at the Rashad structure it was
said to have an abundance of gold and
that the outer walls were lined with it
and it turns out that Mauritania is
loaded with gold and not only that the
richest person ever known to exist in
all of mankind is Mansa Musa of the Mali
Empire which consisted partly of modern
day Mauritania and he was so rich from
gold that he would be richer than Elon
Musk and like Bezos combined almost like
many unfathomable amount of billions of
of dollars so that's another symbol what
year was this oh this is uh 1300s or
1400s yeah there we are 13 12 13 37
great name too man yeah
um but the similarities don't end there
they were said to be an abundance of
elephants which is one reason why
to suggest that Atlantis would have been
in Africa is because well besides the
fact that elephants are known to be in
throughout Africa they used to be
Mauritania they're unfortunately pretty
much extinct there today
um but another little detail that most
people aren't aware of because they
think of Atlantis like oh it must be at
the bottom of the ocean well that's not
exactly how Plato worded it he did
describe that the aftermath of Atlantis
followed a catastrophic event involving
water is that is that what was left of
Atlantis was Reeds of grass and a Shoal
of mud that prevented ships from
navigating to and from and what people
don't realize is that Sahara Africa up
until about 4 500 to 5000 years ago was
totally green it was tropical it had the
largest Network or one of the largest
networks of rivers ever known to exist
it had the largest freshwater lake ever
known to exist which is Mega Lake Chad
which just to put this into perspective
it is if you take all the North American
Great Lakes combined that's 94 000
square miles of surface area whereas
Mega Lake Chad was 139 000. whoa massive
um the additionally uh Atlantis the
capital was said to have a river that
went just north of it or next to it and
the Tom and rasat River went right
through the Rishad structure or just
north of it went all the way to the
Atlas Mountains that I described which
is in modern day Morocco
um and the evidence is that it existed
at that same period of time when
Atlantis was said to be around 11 600
years ago prior to its destruction up
until about 5 000 years ago so going
back to my point like a lot of people
see the Sahara Desert and they don't
realize that this place was unbelievably
different than it is today and one of
the things that's so important is that I
know some people listening will you know
they hear Atlantis they think oh it
didn't exist right whether it existed or
not the the evidence that we're going to
chat about today to show you that there
is conclusive evidence I would say that
catastrophic water erosion that the
ocean had blasted through the Sahara era
tens of millions of years more recently
than previously known
according to the science 56 to 66
million years ago was the time of the
trans-saharan Seaway which was the last
time the ocean blasted through it
however there are a few lines of
evidence that say otherwise besides the
fact that anyone that looks at the
Sahara desert on through you know the
Google Earth app you can see fluvial
striations which is signature traits of
water erosion this is confirmed by other
experts that look into these things as
far like I like to mention Randall
Carlson he's someone that's analyzed the
area and said yes this is catastrophic
water erosion
but so one of the signature lines of
evidence that suggests that the ocean
blasted through it far more recently was
the largest volcano in in Sahara Africa
is in Chad it's Mount KUSI and
there is a lava flow that goes through
it that's dated at 12 000 or so years
ago the volcano itself is supposed to be
somewhere between 1.2 and 2.3 million
years ago but if you look at Mount KUSI
to the South you can see and I don't
know Jamie if you're able to bring up
one of the photos of of that mountain
chain but you can see that the water
erosion cuts off that lava flow
directly to the South yeah keep going
over
a little bit right there okay so go over
a couple that is the mountain and you
can see those striations which are
signature traits of water erosion all
those white blemishes are salt and I
should point out real quick that it is a
confirmed fact that much of the Sahara
has surface level salt and you see those
white blemishes on that mountain that is
not clouds that is not snow those are
salt deposits and surface level salt
that would have been from the ocean that
is what I that is what I suggest because
in the middle of that Caldera you have
huge patches of salt and is it
reasonable to suggest that that salt
existed before that the creation of that
volcano because it seems to me that all
that molten that salt would burn up and
and not only that there is scientific
studies that show that there are
gastropods which are the sea life that
existed inside that Caldera that used to
be a thousand feet deep and dried up
just a few thousand years ago so the
fact that this is an 11
000 foot volcano that has salt on top of
it I would say is corresponding evidence
that the ocean had once went through it
and if you go over a couple more images
Jamie you will see far better images
that show you that okay so notice how it
cuts off you see yeah to the black right
here
that that is a lava flow it's dated
around 12 000 or so years ago and
regardless of whether the volcano or
that water erosion happened 12 000 years
ago or two million years ago that in
itself is evidence that the ocean
blasted through the Sahara Desert
literally 50 to 60 million years more
recently than previously known
and the implications of this as far as
climate science as far as the topic of
geology and cataclysms cannot be
overstated I mean does it not look like
that that water or excuse me that lava
flow was cut off by whatever type of
erosion that is
does it I mean that's yeah completely
yeah it's such a clean line and it it
aligns with all the water erosion marks
that are to the left if it can make that
smaller Jamie
can you make it stretch it out
and oh sorry go ahead nothing it's just
like you could really clearly see that
it looks like a line like a water line
pass through what was uh marked by the
volcanic eruption and this is one thing
I say and like it's it's visible to
anyone that has eyes to see but it turns
out that the Sahara Desert is one of the
least studied places
on earth mostly because it's so
inhospitable it's an average of 125
degrees Fahrenheit much of the year it
is so unbelievably big that just to get
out there I mean you need reliable
aircraft or Vehicles there is most of
the countries out there are I regret to
say third world and that you just don't
have supplies it's not feasible to just
travel out there with a whole team at on
a whim so most most of it is essentially
undocumented and it's not a site that
Sarah as a whole isn't a site that gets
much attention unfortunately Ben we got
to bring you in other words it's going
to talk forever no I was going to say
something that that you mentioned about
the origin of uh I guess the Plato's
description you said it was mud and
grasses was like the aftermath it's it's
interesting it's the topic I've been
exploring recently is that that does
match some of the translations of origin
stories from the ancient Egyptians so
it's it's like that the the Temple of
Horus at edfoods is amazing structure
but it's it's literally covered head to
toe in hieroglyphs and descriptions and
all these types of things but one of the
stories in the translations they do talk
about is this what they would call the
uh the the original point or the the
primordial Mound the primordial Island
they describe it as being an island that
was surrounded by water that was was
sinking and essentially this these Reeds
that were growing on it that created a
Falcons perch and then the God it was
either Horus or Horan and one of the
Falcon Gods uh lights on this perch and
then gains Divinity but as part of that
story I mean they they and then he goes
and forms chemet the uh essentially the
the motherland Egypt and it's it's this
tale of of them I guess their
civilization moving and and migrating to
this new land but they they do talk
about a whole stack of unknown gods and
a whole culture that existed before that
that's it's it's a it's an interesting
correlation it's something that Graham
Hancock speculated about in his work uh
with the Temple of Horus at edfu you
know they they also have you know
catastrophic flood myths and things like
this but it it may be that whatever
prior civilization and it that's might
have been where the dynastic actually
got their Origins from because it seems
clear that they've inherited some things
from the past that's a story they
themselves tell yeah I wasn't aware that
the story of Atlantis had come from
Egypt
that's one of the most bizarre Parts
about it I didn't know this until just a
few years ago either it's like oh wait a
second Plato didn't just Plato his his
distant relative Solon had traveled
there in search of knowledge because
Egypt was the place to go for it and
yeah it was it was the priests of the
Delta that told Solon and he said he
they said that yeah so 6 000 years uh or
nine thousand years sorry prior to the
time of Solon was when the sinking of
this city happened and that that works
out to be
9600 BC so 11 600 years ago which is
bang on exactly where now the geological
evidence points to basically the end of
the younger driest cataclysms like
something we know something happened at
the start at like 12 800 900 years and
then 11 600 years ago was that end of
the younger driest that brought us up
out of the cold spell and into the the
Holocene isn't it crazy that's a full
thousand years and we think about it in
like the same time period like yeah I
mean around that time
yeah 11 600 12 800 we're literally
talking about a thousand [ __ ] years
yes it's so much time it's so much time
that actually if you go from twelve
thousand eight you know so basically
let's say 1200 years the English
language Old English is only like 1400
years and Modern English is only like
four or five hundred years so this is
such a wide a long period of time that
or we weren't even speaking the same
language that in that same you know
thousand years ago it's a I mean you
think of it like that it's like it's a
different world it's nuts and if you
think about the people that lived a
thousand years ago and how they lived